hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2022 american fantasy and drama movie
called fantastic beasts the secrets of
dumbledore it is the third fantastic
beasts movie which takes place in the
wizarding world franchise now focused on
the feud between albus dumbledore and
geller grindelwald
the movie begins with a rendezvous
between albus dumbledore and geller
grindelwald
gellert notices albus file and states
his determination to lead wizards in a
war with humans or muggles
albus seems unable to stop him meanwhile
in china the magi zoologist newt
scamander arrives in a forest and helps
a chilean a rare deer-like magical
creature to give birth
after the baby is born he is suddenly
attacked by three of gellard's minions
led by cretans who are after the newborn
they successfully capture it leaving the
injured nude alone and even attack the
mother chilean unbeknownst to them the
mother manages to give birth to another
chilean before she dies
newt takes the surviving baby and leaves
the forest with the help of one of his
magical beasts from a suitcase
cretans presents the captured chilean to
gellard gellard explains to him that
when a chilean is born a righteous
leader will be elected
after credence is dismissed gellert
slices the chilean's throat effectively
killing it
its pool of blood shows some visions of
the future because the creature has the
ability of precognition
gellert does not know that queenie has
been observing him
meanwhile albus enlists the help of newt
and his brother theseus
he shows them his blood pact made from
his and gellert's blood making them
unable to battle each other or the vile
will strangle its betrayer
thus he needs help from others to defeat
gellard and prevent the war between
wizards and muggles
back in gellert's compound queenie who
can read minds observes credence
she tells him that he is actually a
member of the dumbledore and is asked by
grindelwald to kill albus his own family
because they are both abandoned by him
credence is disturbed by that fact and
demands her to go
however after she leaves she apologizes
through a message she conjures in the
mirror
jacob a muggle who is also queenie's
lover hallucinates seeing her in his
bakery
lolly hicks a teacher of the american
school of wizardry lures him outside by
pretending to be harassed by men
after getting jacob's attention she asks
him to help the wizards
initially hesitant jacob finally agrees
and they teleport to a moving train car
where all other members have gathered
newt introduces jacob to theseus his
brother and head of the british horror
office bunty newt's indispensable
assistant and kama a descendant of an
old wizarding family newt explains that
gellert now masters the ability of
precognition so they have to confuse him
by having no plans at all so he could
not anticipate what will come
lali also suggests they can plan
multiple things simultaneously to
counter gellert's precognition
newt presents the group with gifts from
albus including a wand given to jacob
despite him being a muggle
they then arrive in berlin
comma gets off the train first then
followed by bunty who also carries
newt's suitcase
meanwhile newt theseus lolly and jacob
attend the tea ceremony at the german
ministry of magic hosted by vogel the
current supreme head of the
international confederation of wizards
and the german minister of magic
newt delivers a message for him from
albus saying choose what is right not
what is easy
vogel delivers a speech reminding every
attendee that they will elect the new
supreme head of the international
confederation of wizards in two days
the candidates are lu dao and vicencia
santos
he also says that the council has
absolved grindelwald of its crimes
because of insufficient evidence
the crowd murmurs disagreement
newt and theseus notice gellert's
minions among the crowd and try to
attack them but they fail and theseus is
subdued
newt lolly and jacob leave
at hogwarts minerva mcgonagall informs
albus of what is happening in berlin
while he is having dinner with his
brother aberforth
hearing the news albus quickly leaves
meanwhile aberforth receives mysterious
messages in the mirror
on the other hand grindelwald is sure
cretans can complete the task of killing
albus and prepare to leave with his
minions
albus secretly meets newt and his
friends informing them that theseus has
been taken to the prison of irkstack
newt heads there to retrieve his brother
while jacob and lolly are tasked to
attend a dinner which gellert will also
attend
somewhere else bunty orders newt
suitcase to be replicated into six exact
copies
meanwhile kama visits gellert's place
telling him that he is an admirer
gellert and his minions recognize him as
the brother of little estranged whom
they killed some time ago
gellert relieves him of his pain by
erasing his memories about letta then
invites him inside to talk more about
dumbledore
creedence stalks albus in the streets
but the latter has anticipated it albus
notices a phoenix but credence ensures
him that the phoenix usually following
someone who is dying is following him
not albus
their fight does not last long as
credence is quickly overpowered
albus helps him in the end telling him
that he is sorry that the dumbledore
family abandoned him
meanwhile gellert has a massive crowd
waiting for him outside the ministry of
magic where he receives a vision of
jacob attacking him at the dinner
vogel seeing the massive public support
for gellert decides to make him the
third candidate for supreme head of icw
in irkstag newt has to give up his wand
and pets to be led in by the prison
guard
he notices the prison is full of
scorpions which he confuses by mimicking
their surprise state
he soon learns that a big scorpion
resides at the bottom of the prison and
consumes the prisoners one by one after
freeing theseus they crawl their way out
of the prison and quickly head for
hogwarts
meanwhile during the dinner jacob
observes gellert entering the venue with
queenie and tries to call her but to no
avail
when lolly leaves him for a moment he is
triggered to threaten gellard and uses
the wand albus gave him just like
gellert foresaw earlier lolly foils the
assassination attempt and quickly
teleports jacob and herself away
they regroup with newt and theseus and
hogwarts
there albus explains to them that the
icw supreme head election will take
place in bhutan an asian kingdom that is
also the source of much magic
the election used to involve chilean as
part of its ritual as chilean can sense
if a person truly has a pure heart and
is capable of leading it will bow to the
chosen person then he will be elected as
the supreme head
meanwhile newt notices a mysterious
message in the mirror i want to come
home
he delivers the message to albus who is
just conversed with aberforth albus
tells newt that credence has been
sending those messages and that he is
actually aberfort's biological child
gellert uses necromancy to revive the
chilean carcass it comes back alive then
gellard sees a vision of its twin
he scolds credence for not realizing
there was another chilean and demands it
be found
the twin is safely hidden in newt's
suitcase which they plan to take to
bhutan for the icw meeting to confuse
gellert's minions and to prevent them
from getting the chilean each of them
picks a copy of the suitcase that bundy
has prepared then teleports one by one
to bhutan
newt and his friends wander around
bhutan carrying identical suitcases
dumbledore calms franic jacob telling
him that the chilean is not in his
chosen suitcase
lolly and theseus battle a group of
wizards who chase them but are
overpowered in the end
fortunately their suitcases are also
decoys
meanwhile newt's suitcase is taken by
henrietta vogel's secretary who turns
out to be one of gellard's minions as
well
lolly and theseus encounter comma which
apparently wants to attack them but kama
turns around and attacks gellert's men
instead then join lolly and theseus
queenie encounters jacob and tells him
she has renounced him but jacob calms
her down
henrietta burns newt's suitcase before
giving it back to him the revived
chilean bows to gellert effectively
making him the supreme head
he quickly announces war with the
muggles and tortures jacob
santos helps relieve jacob's pain
whereas queenie sobs beside him
credence stands in gellert's way
exposing the truth to the crowd that the
chilean was dead and that revived so
gellert could manipulate it to choose
him bunty who carries the real suitcase
containing the chilean hands it to newt
and lets him present the real chilean
the crowd then demands re-election
the chilean slowly walks to albus and
finally bows before him but he could not
take the responsibility and encourages
it to find someone equally worthy it
then bows before santos making her the
new supreme head
gellert attacks credence to which albus
and aberforth defend
the clashing spells of albus and gellard
caused the blood pack to be broken and
now gellard and albus can finally face
each other after a brief fight albus
decides not to do anything to him and
ends the fight but other wizards attack
gellard
realizing he has nowhere to go gellert
disappears into thin air
theseus tells albus he needs to find and
defeat gellert
meanwhile aberforth finally embraces
cretans as his son and takes him home
jacob and queenie are married in the
bakery with newt serving as the best man
most of the group attends the wedding
even tina newt's love interest who is
currently busy as the head of macusa or
office
he then notices albus sitting across the
street thanking him for his help then
disappears into the night
afterward newt goes back inside the
bakery subscribe to watch more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching